whether we're looking at the maori
warriors or we look at cultures that dye
their hair or they wear their hair in
some special way all cultures fixate on
appearance the ornate nature of how we
attend to our bodies is a use of energy
and time which obviously has importance
the question that i'm often asked is
well what should i wear you mr navarro
you're always wearing a suit i'm
comfortable wearing a suit but in many
places now rarely is that the case you
can now go into
a town in the united states and possibly
not see one person wearing a suit but i
can tell you that from every study
that's ever been done we prefer people
that are well groomed and well dressed
[Music]
in the 1980s you had women with these
very padded shoulders men with padded
shoulders you had the big hair you had a
lot of blue lining of the eyes power
clothing has always been with us you
could not go into queen isabella's court
unless you were wearing certain attire
the same thing in the court of
versailles a few months ago i was a
studio in california and no one there
was wearing a suit everybody was in
jeans but think about it what happens
during the golden globes what happens
during the academy awards all of a
sudden you don't see anybody in jeans
you see some really elaborate attire why
are they doing that because we are drawn
to this we expect this it communicates
something just because we dress down to
sit around in the office doesn't mean
it's always appropriate the fact that we
see people dressing up for these events
that we see them dressing up to go out
what it indicates is that this is part
of our heritage and it has meaning and
significance
back in the time of pericles what did
the winners of the olympics wear
they wore a wreath around their head all
that sacrifice all that running was
merely to be crowned with a wreath that
non-verbal that little piece of property
that you got to walk around with spoke
volumes the native americans who would
wear the feather headdress the kings in
europe that literally wore crowns places
in the pacific islands where only
royalty were allowed to wear special
headdresses when they were first
contacted in the 1700s the mariners from
a mile out could tell who was the chief
based on the attire and how they were
groomed no different than in the 1400s
the conquistadores had seen this in
mesoamerica there was no question when
cortes and others landed as to who was
in charge who were the leaders who were
the followers it was based on their body
language how they carried themselves how
they were groomed the clothing they wore
in the time of henry v all the way
through henry viii there were strict
guidelines as to
if you were a duke you were supposed to
wear this kind of clothing and this
color if you were a knight you were
entitled to this color and of course
certain colors purple in particular was
reserved for the king and so forth
[Music]
the beauty dividend is controversial but
you can't ignore the research what the
researchers did was they went through a
high school yearbook and they looked at
high school pictures and they had
different people look at them and say
okay which ones do you think are
handsome or which ones do you think are
beautiful and then they went and they
found these people and eight ten years
later one of the things they found that
those people who were selected from a
yearbook as being handsome or beautiful
were earning anywhere from eight to ten
percent more than the same students in
that yearbook you know i'm often asked
maybe i'm not particularly great looking
and i know that there's this concept of
the beauty dividend but you know in my
studies what we find is that actually
can be fixed and it can be fixed really
easy with a makeover where change your
hairdo change what you wear come in
dress differently appearing differently
and that satisfies this concept of of
the beauty dividend now all of a sudden
people view us differently and with with
greater respect we know that faces that
are symmetrical tend to be perceived as
more beautiful and i'm often told by
experts that somebody for instance like
kate moss who has a face where there's a
lot of symmetry contributes to that
beauty what experimenters have done is
they will take a baby that's four or
five months old and they will look at
different pictures and what's
interesting is that even at that young
age five six months of age a baby will
spend more time looking at a beautiful
face than perhaps one that that isn't
there is a beauty dividend
in the same way that there's also a
height dividend malcolm gladwell tells
us in his books that about three percent
of the american population males are
above six two but they account for about
38 percent of senior executives on wall
street it's not that taller people are
smarter what happens is we perceive
these people
differently for instance in
presidential debates the reason why
they're spaced at nine feet apart
usually it's because anything closer
than that then you can see the height
difference between candidates what if
i'm a short person i know giants in
industry that are not very tall but they
compensate that by the exquisite
abilities and skill sets that they bring
all these things can be overcome when i
do coaching especially with with
executives and i say please stop
worrying about what you look like as a
result of how you were born let's take
what we have and let's see what we can
do with it
one of the things that we often see with
a tire is obviously we want to shape
perceptions but many times we see what's
called perception management and you
certainly see this during trials one of
the most recent ones was the case of
elizabeth holmes any comments elizabeth
any comments elizabeth any comments
during the time that she was in business
and she was trying to grow her empire
you saw her dressed very stoically she
dressed with a black turtleneck like
steve jobs and her hair was straight
down and so forth and this is when she's
trying to get investors cut to the chase
she's arrested now she goes to trial and
look how she's softened up her hair's
softened up there's curls the hair is
changed in color her attire is
completely different than what she wore
before
including the fact that one of the bags
that she took to court was a diaper bag
this is perception
management does it work
maybe sometimes it does most of the time
i think people see through that but the
fact that we use these things is for a
reason and that is that it does affect
perceptions and with a trial
maybe that perception is useful with
just one person and that holdout could
make the difference in your
in your case
[Music]
when the topic of trust comes up
consistency and behavior consistency and
style becomes a big factor what is trust
trust is our ability to relax because we
know they will not let us down because
consistently they behave in certain ways
and so we don't worry that they're going
to show up on time they always do we
don't worry that they're going to show
up with clean clothes they do that's
consistency consistency contributes to
what we consider trust
there are many cultures in which we have
coming of age rituals and you certainly
see this in latin america and in europe
where you would have these debutant
balls where the young women usually 13
to 15 would be introduced to society and
from that moment on they're no longer
children they are eligible for courtship
in latin america and in many parts of
the world you have the quinceaneras
where at the age of 15 they too are
introduced to the world
this flamboyant productions of the
colorful attire it is the annunciation
of the family formally saying please
welcome our daughter into society and
that from this point forward
society is to treat her and respect her
differently
[Music]
you may have noticed that on social
media there's an inordinate amount of
dressing up i'm astonished at these
young people on tick tock how much
makeup they wear how much eyeliner the
eyelashes that they wear obviously they
have been getting it that
this matters so whether you're in a
virtual environment whether you're on
zoom on skype or on tick-tock or any of
these things what we're seeing with
these trend setters is this uh obvious
need to dress better and to wear makeup
to stand out they're in essence saying
this is important and if you have 3
million 5 million 40 million followers
there may just be something to that
[Music]
some things will never change that we
will use clothing attire and our
presence to communicate who we are
what we are what we believe in and to
speak about
ourselves
[Music]